l'entrée de la russie dans le conflit
syrien est elle une bonne ou une
inquiétante nouvelle d'après vous une
très bonne nouvelle enfin enfin une
action claire nette et urgente
[Musique]
tant on a traîné sur cette affaire et je
constate qu'il ya qu un chef d'état dans
dans le monde aujourd'hui c'est vladimir
poutine qui assume ses actes et qui a
compris le danger de l'état islamique
voilà c'est tout et à un moment il faut
choisir et on a en face des dirigeants
européens ou américains qui sont
complètement hors de l'histoire au sens
au grand sens du mot histoire est-ce que
là la lutte contre des shu légitime
toutes les alliances ou tous les
soutiens y compris en faveur de vladimir
poutine dont l'armée a bombardé à la
fois des rebelles modérée des
djihadistes et des milliers de civils
côté chic très heureux que vous passiez
ce passage parce qu'on nous ressort la
phrase sur poutine en ce moment et dans
le contexte où je l'aï dit elle était
parfaite pourquoi parce que il ya eu
tant de morts sur nos trottoirs à paris
par la faiblesse
des occidentaux qui n'ont pas su
justement choisir etc ont laissé des ch
tu es tout ça par haine du régime syrien
comme ils ont enlevé saddam hussein en
irak avec un drame où kadhafi et dieu
sait si je suis pas pour kadhafi ni pour
saddam hussein ni pour assad mais on a
laissé le djihadisme envahir l'afrique
parce qu'on a des dingues des
va-t-en-guerre de salon qui qui ont
préféré laisser le djihadisme que de
soutenir des chefs d'état qui était pas
parfait mais qui au moins évité le
djihadisme donc moi je maintiens que la
russie a eu raison d'intervenir et que
si la france et les états unis avaient
maintenu des relations avec assad et a
été et est intervenue contre des chemins
on n'aurait pas eu besoin des russes
c'est tout vous avez les occidentaux
sont intervenus et massivement des
occidentaux ils ont armé les islamistes
en voulant armée de modérer syrien les
armes se sont retrouvés du côté du jihad
une intervention enfin vous interpelle
une intervention on ira très vite après
est en tout cas après les attentats et
bien après et quant aux bars et son fils
quant au civil vous avez raison c'est
abominable la guerre mais les américains
quand ils sont intervenus en irak et là
j'avais beaucoup soutenu de villepin
pour ces chiffres américains
bombardaient délibérément des écoles des
zobals et l'américain ont fait des les
russes l'ont fait centaines de milliers
de morts en irak donc ils sont pas
meilleurs que les russes parce que et je
ne les accable pas ils sont partis dans
une logique de guerre effrayante en irak
et moi je si vous voulez je préférerais
qu'on ait un dominique de villepin à
jacques chirac en ce moment qu'un
emmanuel macron mais pas de de
complaisance ou d'admiration
particulièrement mais le régime au laser
footing non si vous retrouvez si vous
écoutez bien mon extrait et je vous en
remercie je veux le ressortir
dans le contexte il y avait rien à
redire à ce que je disais
[Musique]